there are reports of heavy fighting at
the azov style steel plant in the
besieged port city of mariupol ukrainian
forces inside the plant say russian
soldiers have stormed the facility
that's something russian officials have
denied now the reports come as a
three-day ceasefire announced by moscow
is due to begin on thursday to allow
more civilian evacuations as of style is
the last stronghold of ukraine's
resistance in the city
ukrainian president vladimir zelinski
said a prolonged ceasefire is vital to
bring more people to safety
we hope to continue rescuing people from
azov style from mario paul
there are still civilians left there
women children
to save them we need to continue the
ceasefire
the ukrainian side is ready to provide
it it takes time just to lift people out
of those basements out of those
underground shelters
now russia denies reports that it is
trying to storm the steel plant emanuel
shaz is part of dw's team in ukraine and
she has more now on those latest
developments in mario paul
exactly russia denied us that its troop
was storming the plan but it's something
that ukrainian
authorities have
said uh overnight so what we know is
that there has been a heavy shelling
over the steel plant over the other star
steel plant what we also know is that
there are still hundreds of civilians
along
thousands of soldiers who are trapped in
that steel plant they haven't seen
daylight for two months evacuations
there are rendered very difficult
because of the constant artillery fight
because of the constant shelling which
makes it for a lot of rebels to go
through before
civilians can be reached and evacuated
yesterday the united nations said that
344 people had been successfully
evacuated from the mariupol area towards
zaparica but hopes for more evacuations
of course fade
at a time of heavy fights fighting on
mariupol as is the case as of right now
that was dw's emma shaz reporting from
live now meanwhile ukraine's armed
forces are claiming victories in the
eastern kharkiv region after taking back
several towns there but airstrikes on
the second largest city kahiv continue
and moscow's offensive is taking its
toll
an amusement park
rocked by missiles in her cave
cctv footage captured these shocking
images
ukrainian authorities say this was one
of dozens of russian airstrikes an
attempt to heighten the kremlin's
eastern offensive
as ukrainian forces retake some villages
in the harkeev region
scenes of destruction greet them
after spending two months under russian
control
residents are still in shock
we lived in the basement for two months
they wouldn't let us out we were sitting
in the basement we didn't have anything
to eat or drink there was no water we
were getting dirty black water from the
well and we drank it
to the west
a power plant was hit
russian authorities have confirmed they
are targeting infrastructure including
railway lines
they say the west is using them to send
arms to ukraine
and for more we can speak now to ruth
diamond she's a russia analyst at the
department of war studies at king's
college london dr diamond welcome to dw
can we start um with the battle for the
last holdout in mario paul the azov
style steel plant now tactically this
battle is like to be likely to be very
different isn't it and difficult uh for
russian forces who are trying to
dislodge the ukrainian uh forces who
know the site very well how would you
say um is it likely to play out
well it's very hard to tell of course
excuse me but what we do know is that
um that a lot of this is taking place
underground that um
that the plant has been reinforced over
a long time has been designed to
withstand a siege
um
but clearly russia is now committing to
taking the plants so um
one has to assume that eventually it is
most likely that they will be successful
but
it's not going to be easy for them as as
far as we can tell
now russia is expected to escalate its
attacks in the run-up to may 9th which
is obviously an important day in russia
marking the soviet union's defeat of
nazi uh germany how important would you
say is it for russian forces to be able
to declare some kind of victory in
ukraine um and and
uh you know what means do you think that
they will be willing to go to to secure
this victory
yes i mean clearly they do seem to be
strongly committed to being able to
declare some kind of victory um on may
the 9th and
um it looks as if what they they might
do is declare mariupol taken which is
perhaps one reason why we're seeing
this attempt um
that we've just been talking about now
um
there are reports that russian uh media
figures are turning up in the city that
uh ground is being prepared
to facilitate a victory parade um so
that may be one place where where they
can attempt to declare victory
in a sense it's quite um it's easier for
putin than it would otherwise be because
he's really set the terms for this war
and so he can declare victory um really
when he feels like it and given the
control that uh that the kremlin has
over russian media
really is it's pretty likely that if
putin says that some kind of victory has
been achieved um that's what the russian
media are going to accept so he can
really set the terms for this i think
do you think that we are going to see a
declaration of uh all-out war from the
kremlin
it's it's very difficult to call because
of course one thing that we've seen over
the last few months is
is how the the kremlin can do the
unexpected um
but
uh
it's not necessarily something we might
expect it's there's no obvious benefit i
think to a an all-out declaration of war
um you know we've seen an increase in in
fighting in certain areas and
it's possible that um
belarus may now being used to put some
pressure on ukraine and in the north
um it's not totally clear what the
advantage would be um of a declaration
of war uh on the ninth and indeed that
that could prove to be unpopular in
russia so i think the kremlin is going
to have to be careful about that
dr ruth diamond from king's college
london thank you so much
thank you
you